hello there you're watching the press
preview first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and in the
next half hour we'll see what's making
the headlines with the sunday times
political editor caroline wheeler and
the journalist and author rachel shabby
welcome very much chibo thanks a lot for
joining us so let's take a look and see
what is on some of those front pages the
i writes pm battles to contain tory
sleaze backlash as boris johnson
prepares to face parliament over this
handling of the owen patterson scandal
the metro also focuses on conservative
mps joining the growing backlash against
mr johnson despite one senior minister
dismissing the row over sleaze as a
storm in a teacup
meanwhile the guardian claims an
exclusive with news that ministers had
to be prevented by an official watchdog
from breaching the neutrality rules on
hiring the new chairs of the bbc and the
british film institute
the express says a brexit trade war is a
looming as the row with the eu over the
northern ireland protocol escalates
the times says that the government's
planning to bar gps from taking jobs in
affluent areas to force them to work in
poorer more deprived ones
the telegraph quotes the former health
secretary matt hancock who says the law
should require health workers to be
fully vaccinated
the daily mail dives into research which
reveals that we inhale up to 7 000
microplastic particles every day
the financial times leads on an
investigation by the french authorities
into the uk steel magnet sanji gupta's
empire over alleged misuse of corporate
assets and money laundering claims that
he has denied
and the daily star reports on national
rail special trains that will make sure
that we don't run out of wine due to the
trucker shortage this christmas
story of the day uh we're joined tonight
by caroline wheeler and rachel shabby uh
lovely to see you both and and the
sleaze uh allegations uh and the row and
golfing boris johnson and his government
don't really doesn't really seem to be
going away it's gone a little way off
a couple of the front pages
but carolina
it's unlikely to to
um lose traction when we have this
parliamentary sleaze um committee in the
commons tomorrow
no exactly and uh you know i think
george eustis the environment section
was sent out this morning to try and
defuse the row uh a little bit as he
took to the airwaves and actually i
think what he did was to actually put
rocket boosters under it having spoken
to conservative mps uh this afternoon
they seem uh even more annoyed than they
were sort of on wednesday thursday
friday a suggestion that this was always
just storming a tea cup uh that uh boris
johnson doesn't like throwing uh people
under the bus for minor misdemeanors uh
as he described uh has really sort of uh
annoyed a number of the benches
particularly in the 2019 intake and the
prime minister's now got to endure three
hours
of debate tomorrow uh when the
opposition party will lob pretty much
everything they've got at him uh in
terms of the sleaze that they perceive
surrounds the government starting from
uh the owen patterson affair but i'm
sure that
he'll be here about the wallpaper saga
uh potentially the holiday to musty the
holiday to majorca uh it's sort of
endless the uh the number of stories
that they could potentially
dig up more dirt to throw it here on so
it's going to be a pretty uncomfortable
day tomorrow i would imagine for boris
johnson
and rachel it does seem that that
it doesn't matter you know what boris
johnson does that
his popularity amongst the electorate
doesn't really seem to diminish that
that the sleaze scandals that he he's
faced you know that carolyn just talked
about haven't really affected polling
but but could it be now that it's the
back benches that will be his downfall
it does seem to be and and uh
caroline's uh analysis and reporting
certainly sort of lends weight to that
argument i i suppose you know that the
backlash was quite unexpected for boris
johnson and it's also
interesting that it did dominate
all the national newspapers for the last
week including of course um some of his
supporters so that was quite telling in
itself
and i think the problem here is that
you know he's crossed a line in terms of
um
the sort of integrity of parliament as
the um
house speaker uh lindsey hoyle has been
quite furious about as well
and you know that's a really big deal
one of the reasons that the public loses
faith in politics is precisely that is
that it's seen as corrupt it's seen as
you know rigged and not for them and
that in itself
just really undermines democracy so you
can see
uh why the issue has provoked so much
fury um inside uh johnson's government
but really across parliament as well
and
and caroline um
you know
in terms of what is going to happen
tomorrow
um how bad could it be for boris johnson
we have to remember that this is an
emergency debate that's been tailored by
the opposition party so nothing that
happens tomorrow is going to be binding
in any way and even if they did do bring
forward a vote it's likely to be
symbolic rather than anything that's
actually going to mean anything in terms
of the way forward um i think it's going
to be bruising i think there's going to
be a lot of language but we've seen
quite a lot of that already today uh we
saw sanam debonair the shadow leader of
the commons actually calling on boris
johnson and indeed on jacob rees-mogg
the leader of the house of commons to
consider their positions over all of
this and we've seen
again in recent days former prime
minister john major describing the
government as being politically corrupt
so it already is uh sort of at uh you
know quite heightened levels um and i
think tomorrow will just give opposition
mps another
another opportunity to sort of um
flame it up a bit and really sort of
stick the knife in in terms of um you
know their views on on the
behavior but will it change anything not
at this point i mean what we're
expecting uh at the end of the day is
that we think that this lindsay will may
make some kind of intervention as rachel
said quite rightly there um he does feel
privately we understand that the
reputation of parliament has been sort
of dragged through the mud and it may be
down to him to try and sort out the
problem given that we currently have a
situation where the standards committee
you know has effectively been dismantled
by that devote last week um and there
needs to be something put there back in
its place
um so it's going to be an interesting
day whether it will actually change
anything obviously remains to be seen
and let's just remind us of how the
papers are
are taking it the ice its front page pm
battles to contain tory sleeves backlash
uh the metro um gone for the slightly
cheekier
storm in a sleaze cup um the guardian
too as well as well
they have
got this exclusive that ministers had to
be prevented from breaching new charity
rules for the new chairs of the bbc and
the british film institute as well
rachel so it
it does kind of add weight doesn't it to
what you were saying a little earlier
that there is the sense that perhaps
some politicians at the moment seem to
feel that they are above the rules
it does seem to be the case doesn't it
and i think that that's the question
that might go beyond uh the sort of
parliamentary machinations that caroline
just outlined in the sense of
how actually do we hold politicians to
account and what do we do about
politicians having second jobs that
uh seem to lend themselves to this sort
of uh corruption and misbehavior and um
open democracy which has been of course
running a lot of this excellent
reporting on corruption alongside the
sunday times has got an article by liz
david barrett she's a professor of
governance and integrity at sussex
university and she talks about all of
this including you know the sort of
story raised by the guardian in terms of
state capture so she says that you know
this is a worrying trend it's where the
uk starts to resemble orbans hungary or
erdogan's turkey
where
um you know
minority interests uh
capture the state and the government you
know is democratically elected but then
uses
uh that power to rewrite the laws in its
favor and that's why this is also
troubling that you know we now have a
situation where
you know why do why are ministers
allowed to have these you know
consultancy roles or mps even allowed to
have these consultancy roles where it
does suggest that they are serving
interests other than the public that
they were elected to serve and i think
that that's a question that might
actually extend beyond the parliamentary
debates that we'll see in the next few
days indeed uh just a minute left in
this half um but caroline let's let's
look at the a story uh this is inside
the telegraph and this is about electric
car buyers and the um the fact that
lithium costs are going up so it
potentially is going to mean that going
green is going to become a bit more
expensive
yeah not exactly what the uh government
want to hear at the moment we know that
the uh the whole sort of electric car
revolution is very much part of their
drive to sort of build back better build
back greener but obviously
in terms of the debate around climate
change uh we've heard quite a lot about
uh the switch to electric cars as part
of the debates at the cop 26 climate
change summit up in glasgow and this was
supposed to be the sort of feather in
the cap of the government you know we're
supposed to be leading the world in
terms of this technology so actually any
notion that prices are rising and this
uh particular report suggests that the
cost differential
between an electric vehicle um and a
sort of normal vehicle could be as much
as 10 000 pounds
and obviously consumers tend to vote
with their feet
when it comes to price um and so if
you're trying desperately hard to
convince people to use greener
technology um you're really going to
struggle if that then has a much bigger
price tag attached to it so this really
isn't the news that the government would
be hoping for particularly not this week
as we come towards that um the sort of
end of the summit next weekend indeed
rachel this is matt hancock suggesting
that nhs staff should be mandatorily
jabbed against covid what are your
thoughts
that's right this is the telegraph
reporting uh matt hancock former health
secretary's first major intervention
um
since leaving government now he's saying
that the government should bring forward
the um making it compulsory for the nhs
it's 1.5 million staff
to be
um vaccinated currently i think
ministers want to wait until spring but
that would be too late uh for the sort
of winter intensity of pressure on the
nhs this is a really difficult one um
this mandatory regulation is coming into
care homes this week
um
and it's thought that some care her
staff
left
care and went into the nhs to avoid that
regulation and now you know looks like
that regulation is following them but
it's a difficult one because as labour
has said the worry is that
you know a lot of people will leave the
nhs staff will leave
um if this
law is introduced
thus putting an extra strain
on on the health service so it's a very
difficult one to manage
and caroline the front of the mail um
their story is about micro plastics now
we we know of course in here at sky we
we've spoken a great deal about micro
plastics in the oceans and in our in in
in our foods but this is about
microplastics more generally in the home
in synthetic materials
yeah that's right it's a sort of classic
uh scarce story and to some extent about
sort of killer in your own home really
the suggestion that there are up to a
hundred times more particles than we had
ever thought just you know wafting
around in uh sort of you know
things that we have around our
of our homes you know um so there's real
concern about the impact that can happen
this study basically talking about the
effects on people's health um when it
comes to these micro plastics and uh you
know really worrying actually given you
know if you're a mum like me i mean
plastic is just absolutely everywhere
the sorts of things they're talking
about here and like children's toys
everything seems to be made of plastic
now and if this now is genuinely a risk
uh to our health um then it's very
concerning reading
and finally rachel i don't know why
we've come to you with this story um but
it's about trains being put on for
christmas just to make sure that we can
all have our white wine tell us more
um yeah well you know obviously a
priority for christmas but that you know
to try and
try and bypass the any potential
uh shortages
to do with you know supply chain issues
um that have been plaguing the uk uh
partly because of brexit partly because
of the pandemic
um this is at the laying on of special
trains
delivering us white wine
so that we don't have to deal with any
shortages heaven forbid cover the
festive maybe maybe all the grown-ups
could but just put it on their list to
santa and he'd be able to sort it out
i'm sure
caroline and rachel thank you so much